boa tarde gente muito legal começar a
minha fala depois da fala do bruno
porque é uma espécie de figura viva do
que eu venho falar aqui pra vocês como
criar um capitalismo improvável
e aí eu queria começar minha fala
pedindo pra vocês juntos pra gente fazer
um processo de imaginar um futuro um
pouco diferente o capitalismo um pouco
diferente um exercício de futuro imagina
comigo um futuro em que as nossas
relações inclusive as relações
comerciais acontecem de pessoas para
pessoas
a gente compra de gente que está perto a
gente compra de gente que coloca a mão
na massa a gente compra de gente que faz
que cria inventa a gente compra e aí não
precisa ser um processo de compra
financeira mas a gente compra idéias
como a idéia do bruno
imagina que nesse futuro essas relações
comerciais são sim afetivas alguém vende
porque me encantado com aquilo que está
vendendo
vocês viram o olho dele brilha de tanta
paixão a falar do que está falando
nessas pessoas elas são encantados com o
que fazem com que elas de fato acreditam
as pessoas que moram nesse futuro elas
acreditam nas transformações que o
produto ou serviço a idéia o projeto
negócio delas causa o impacto positivo
que as idéias delas podem causar no
mundo
nesse novo futuro a gente compra e vende
com sentido porque de fato a gente quer
a transformação que uma outra pessoa tá
vendendo o por que aquela transformação
faz sentido pra gente fazer aquilo é
importante pra gente nesse futuro também
a gente trabalha com propósito a gente
não trabalha só para bater cartão mas a
gente trabalha pra deixar o nosso
carinho no mundo porque na hora que a
gente foi embora a gente quer que de
alguma forma o nosso legado sem
o uso da palavra legado mas as
transformações que a gente trouxe o que
esse ser humano trouxe para o mundo elas
fiquem de alguma forma elas impactam o
mundo à nossa volta
nesse futuro também empreendedorismo
está em tudo quanto é lugar
o empreendedorismo nas escolas o
empreendedorismo está na no bar o
empreendedorismo está nas ruas
o empreendedorismo está inclusive nas
empresas ou nos governos
o empreendedorismo não é uma palavra
chique mas sim um modo de vida o modo de
ver a vida o modo de pegar as
dificuldades da pedrinha deve ser
eu vou passar como é que o transforma
uma pedra um desvio de rota
mas eu continuo caminhando nesse futuro
também existem novas formas de trabalho
que vão muito além da clp ou da lpda a
gente nem sabe que novas formas de
trabalho são essas
mas elas vão ser mais horizontais elas
vão ser pessoas participando criando
juntas novos futuros elas vão inclusive
cooperativas colaborações projetos elas
são centralizadas
elas não são verticais as pessoas se
envolvem coisas a todo momento porque
faz sentido envolver com coisas quando
eu comecei a minha transformação
eu comecei pensando em mim mesmo ponto
eu não estava pensando em alguma forma
ajudar outra pessoa eu não estava
pensando em como o que eu estava fazendo
pode impactar o outro eu não estava
pensando como que aquilo que eu fazia
poderia reverberar no outro simplesmente
queria resolver a minha vidinha eu
queria conseguir ver os meus talentos
eu queria usar aquilo que eu sabia fazer
eu queria ganhar meu dinheirinho ser
feliz fazendo o que eu gostava não
queria envolver em projetos ou idéias
que não fazia o meu olho brilhar meu
coração vibrar
eu comecei por mim só que em algum
momento eu percebi que não tinha a ver
comigo só comigo tinha a ver com outras
pessoas e que outras pessoas assim como
eu
também estavam ao tentar de alguma forma
se encontrar impactam outras pessoas ao
seu redor e eu vejo esse momento que a
gente está vivendo hoje como uma espécie
de fermentação o mundo está borbulhando
o mundo tá igual o pão sovado as bolhas
não saiu dali de dentro do pão e estão
começando a se encontrar bolhas maiores
e cada vez maiores em algum momento que
eu quero é que vira uma boina e que essa
bolha seja grande o suficiente para dar
conta de abraçar o mundo
chame de economia colaborativa economia
criativa economia da gratidão economia
social
chame como quiser mas o que está
acontecendo é que tem um monte de gente
operando transformações no mundo através
de um jeito diferente de olhar para si
mesmo como a gente chegou até aqui a
gente teve primeiro a revolução agrícola
e suas plantavam pessoas trabalhavam
para outro dentro dessas terras
e essas coisas chegavam outras pessoas
depois a gente caminhou para a revolução
industrial máquinas fábricas mais valia
marx
depois a gente foi para a revolução da
informação faculdade conhecimento
advogados médicos depois agora agora a
gente está na era da dos conceitos ou
era conceitual que vale a experiência
vale tudo aquilo que é intangível tudo
aquilo que cabe dentro da minha cabeça
cabe dentro da cabeça de bruno e cabe
dentro da cabeça de várias as pessoas
que vão passar por esse palco e cabe
dentro da cabeça de vocês
agora o que vai ser com que esse futuro
que a gente está construindo por que
venhamos e convenhamos uma coisa é certa
do jeito que tá funcionando
não dá pra ficar
quais são os problemas nesse mundo gente
o que é que está acontecendo alguns só
pequenos do sul que está acontecendo no
mundo hoje joão peço dos recursos da
terra um terço foi usado nas últimas
três décadas
em 30 anos a gente foi capaz de acabar
com mais de 30% do que existe por cento
das pessoas nesse planeta tem mais
riqueza do que os 99% restantes por
cento tem mais riqueza e os 99 restantes
a gente usou a gente está usando 50%
mais rapidamente os recursos da terra do
que a própria terra ou a abundância da
terra é capaz de gerar a gente
ultrapassou em velocidade e por último
80% das pessoas infelizes no trabalho e
um monte e querendo empreender porque
empreendedorismo nasce como uma forma
das pessoas fazerem aquilo que faz
sentido era não quero quero bater cartão
pra simplesmente ganhar meu salário no
final do mês
quero bater cartão mesmo que seja de uma
empresa para fazer alguma coisa que faz
sentido pra mim mas como a gente não
encontra propósito a gente possa gastar
porque a gente acha que comprar alguma
coisa vai preencher um vazio que no
fundo não se preenche com coisa se
preenche com propósito se preenche com a
gente fazendo alguma coisa que faça
sentido para a alma da gente
o nosso propósito a gente vive sem
propósito o nosso presente a gente vive
sem propósito
a gente vive para trabalhar a gente
trabalha sem trazer a gente confunde ser
romper a gente compra exageradamente
sentindo simplesmente comprar a gente
lucra ganha dinheiro serviço
a gente lucra simplesmente por lucrar e
não porque a gente quer de fato que
aquela coisa que a gente está vendendo
impacto o outro positivamente o que está
acontecendo gente a gente vive o mundo
acelerado inclusive aqui né
a gente vive muito pouco a gente consome
muito ea gente trabalha muito mais e aí
o que eu quero o que eu acho pelo menos
pra minha vida é que a gente precisa
consumir sim mas a gente pode também
viver e trabalhar porque o trabalho não
é a coisa mais importante da vida mas
ele é uma parte importante especialmente
a gente trabalha com alguma coisa que
faz sentido pra gente e que ajuda a
gente a ajudar o mundo o que está
acontecendo na minha opinião que é o
mundo mundo entrou em rehab
todo mundo parou e falou pessoal do
jeito que está não dá para ficar
e aí o mundo tá se matriculando em uma
academia
já comecei a comer mais saudável tá né
assistindo coisas legais meditando mundo
só que na verdade nós somos as células
desse mundo nós somos as bolhas desse
mundo
no fundo quem está procurando e reb
somos nós quem está buscando fazer essa
transformação somos nós
e qual é o caminho dessa transformação
seu vivo com o propósito eu sou capaz de
customizar o meu sucesso
deixo ninguém falou que é importante pra
mim a não ser eu mesma
eu não deixo de falar que eu tenho
obrigatoriamente comprar um apartamento
que eu tenho obrigatoriamente que ter
carro que eu tenho que usar a roupa do
momento da fashion com que eu tenho
obrigatoriamente que têm emprego
eu quero o que é o sucesso parece pra
mim
o que é viver feliz pra mim e quando
faço isso eu passo a comprar com mais
sentido porque sim eu compro mas eu não
compro amplo ou não compro para
preencher vazios
eu compro por necessidade eu compro sim
porque aqui talvez me encante de alguma
forma que possa me ajudar a ter uma vida
melhor mas o comprar
passa a ser um exercício inclusive de
sentido e de propósito e vender também
se eu crie uma plataforma como essa eu
me dedico a colocar energia nessa
plataforma para que ela seja o melhor
possível pela aquela impacto no mundo
o melhor jeito possível pra sentir a
vender a sentir a vender alguma coisa
que tem propósito porque existe algum
ser humano ou vários
na outra ponta estão visando exatamente
disso que eu tenho para oferecer e essa
troca passa a ser uma troca por
propósito e aí a gente passa inclusive a
incentivar negócios de propósito que a
gente passa a usar o dinheiro como
posição política a gente passa a usar o
nosso poder financeiro para mostrar para
o mundo o que está pensando como a gente
o que não está pensando como agente
quais idéias produtos serviços pessoas
estão contribuindo para um mundo melhor
e quais idéias produtos serviços ainda
não chegaram lá porque a gente tem que
torcer para que todo mundo chegue o
momento a essa constatação
isso significa então gente inventar um
capitalismo de significado o capitalismo
que existe para alimentar propósitos
como melhorar as cidades com a solução
então quem sou eu pra apresentar uma
solução mas eu venho pensando em algumas
práticas novas práticas para inventar
novas práticas para mudar o capitalismo
mas colaboração e menos competição mais
criação e menos consumo mais
distribuição e - acúmulo mais presença e
menos pressa mas fluxo e menos controle
mais propósito e menos status mais reuso
e - descarte mais em desenvolvimento -
crescimento mais simpatia - diz conexão
mas a abundância e - escassez ea
abundância significa que é abundante
para todo mundo isso significa também
mas nós e menos eu
significa que a gente vai voltar ao que
talvez tenha sido a essência do
capitalismo porque é bonito pensei
comigo se não é bonito alguém pegar o
seu tempo que é o bem mais precioso que
essa pessoa tem usar esse tempo para
fazer alguma coisa que seja bonita que
seja útil que seja prática que seja
inspiradora e seja qualquer outra coisa
e essa coisa que na verdade é resultado
do poder criativo e do tempo dessa
pessoa vai ser vendida e colocado à
disposição de outros seres humanos e vai
impactar positivamente a vida de outros
seres humanos na essência o capitalismo
é bonito
na essência o conexão existe troca
financeira e talvez a gente chega no
futuro e nem exista mas o dinheiro não
sei
o mais importante disso tudo é que são
seres humanos pessoas trocando com
outras pessoas pessoas investindo no seu
melhor e disponibilizando expor outras
pessoas e essas pessoas optando por
também usar o seu dinheiro que na
verdade é resultado do seu tempo
em pessoas porque seu filho
eu gasto meu tempo para investir em
outras pessoas que também estão gastando
seu tempo e subir um ciclo e se ele for
assim ele é bonito
ele ficou assim agora lá atrás quando eu
comecei eu não pensava eu saiba só em
mim de uma forma egoísta mas foi um
lugar onde eu aprendi a começar e eu
acho que é um lugar onde todo mundo deve
começar porque o agente investigando
essas entranhas internas
a gente vai começar conseguir pensar
exatamente o que significa viver
consumir trocar se conectar aprender
junto com criar colaborar
o que quer que seja que a gente escolheu
fazer um tempo que a gente tem aqui eu
não fácil pra ser bem sincera idéia de
como é de fato esse capitalismo
improvável mas eu só tenho uma certeza
que é o jeito que está já está claro que
não dá pra ficar obrigado
[Aplausos]